all right
we're live for the first
ama of uh 2022 so
hopefully we'll be able to do these each
month
i already have a couple questions lined
up and uh some of them look like
good ones so dammit albert has a complex
one
here my friends young men disgruntled
with feminists absolutely worship jordan
peterson
and his work how can i get them out of
that hole and which living thinkers
should i recommend to them
so i mean the first thing to say is that
you're not going to get them out of that
hole if they absolutely worship jordan
peterson or any other person
you don't have enough leverage no matter
what you do to get them out of that
short of like you know
cult deprogramming stuff and i i doubt
you're up for that i mean anybody who's
foolish enough to absolutely worship
a figure as like you know the guidance
for life um
it's just an immature and and kind of
silly attitude and if you get them if
you let's say you were able to get them
weaned away from that they would
immediately go and find somebody else to
absolutely worship um so let's treat
that as if that's hyperbole right your
friends aren't just nutters uh who are
completely
you know devoted to some half rate
thinker uh who everybody's going to like
you know if they remember it all they're
going to make fun of 20 30 years from
now
um let's think about the rest of this
your friends are young men disgruntled
with feminists
right there you know red flags go off
for me what feminists um you know
there's there's a million different
kinds of feminists out there and anybody
who is disgruntled with an entire class
it's got some serious character flaws
and probably intellectual deficits as
well
i i question whether you actually want
to remain friends with these people the
way that you're describing them
i think you should get yourself some
better friends you know and and start
over there's no you know
there's no like
requirement that you
help out these these people who clearly
have you know some pretty weird and
whacked out ways of looking at society
at the life of the mind at how they
ought to run their life and i would
actually suggest that anybody who's
disgruntled with feminists probably
actually ought to read some actual
feminists rather than
talking about you know how disgruntled
they are um you know simone de bevoir
mary wollstonecraft some of these first
second wave feminists where it was you
know primarily not just about cultural
critique but also
about equality and treating human beings
as human beings you know that's feminism
too
as is plato you know when he tells us in
the republic that women and men have the
same basic dispositions an array of
dispositions they can be you know
epitheumatic
they can be thumatic they can be logical
you know this is something running
throughout the entire history of
philosophy so
you know i long story short you don't
have to try to wean them away from
things that's not your job and you
should find better friends and
you know what living thinkers there's an
entire host of great thinkers out there
i mean you could recommend to them
aleister mcintyre julianas you know my
friend and colleague john sellers
another friend and colleague chris gill
all these people who are engaged with
the history of philosophy and don't have
some
half-baked you know poorly
researched takes on things but actually
you know know what the hell they're
talking about you know for example
jordan peterson
when he uses the word marxist you got to
be like this guy doesn't know a damn
thing about marxism
alistair mcintyre was a marxist and
actually knows a lot about marxism and
knows which parts were useful and which
parts weren't um but peterson has nice
little sound bites and and the other the
last thing i'll say about peterson is
if this were 10 years ago and people
were like oh this jordan peterson guy he
seems to be kind of you know interesting
he's got some good stuff to say you know
they could be forgiven for that but
at this point in time when you look at
his history
and the stuff he's you know publicly
declared and just his twitter account
and the crazy crap that he writes in
there
um
anybody who would be a follower of him i
i can't take seriously at all so
and i think you shouldn't either
all right philosophical conquest have
you read the sickness onto death by
sergeant kierkegaard yeah i think the
first time i read it was probably 30
years ago
and we actually had a reading group on
it in
grad school and i've taught it a number
of times what are your thoughts on the
work in kierkegaard in general kicker
kierkegaard is a really important
existentialist thinker he's also very
interesting not just as one of the you
know great grandfathers of
existentialism but in his own right
sickness on to death is a really great
work it's nice and short but complex and
i'm hoping uh i was hoping to get some
video shot on it for the existentialism
class i'm i'm teaching this semester
which starts uh
uh two days from now but obviously i
haven't gotten those done but hopefully
in the future i'll be able to get some
uh things on on kierkegaard's uh
sickness on to death as you know i've
already got like fear and trembling and
um
crowd is untruth and
present age
um and i do have some longer videos on
philosophical fragments but it would be
cool to to do some stuff some core
concept videos on that
all right neil says in your bookshelf
tour you mentioned you had some of the
works of lenin and stalin i mentioned
it's at lenin i didn't say anything
about stalin what do you think of them
and their works philosophically or
politically
i mean stalin was essentially a hack who
was good at you know gaining power and
then iced everybody else out lenin is
an important marxist theorist doesn't
mean that he has the answers to
everything and he's writing within a
situation so somebody well worth reading
just like so many other people
are well worth reading
even says uh hope uh i'm doing well in
the new year yeah i mean so far haven't
been sick
um you know everybody in the household
is doing okay there's a lot of
scrambling on the part of my wife and i
to get our classes ready to roll not
least since milwaukee institute of art
and design
moved all the classes online for the
first two weeks due to covid which
doesn't affect me but affects my my wife
you know and we're going to a nice event
tonight and what else you know i've been
working out and
getting some other things ready i've got
a reading group that starts monday as
well
so
all right uh nuclear glue is everything
false silly question obviously not nl
here's a question any opinions on glob i
dare to unreadable have you read it and
what do you think
so
um i have read it and i think it's not a
very good work um i
divide derrida's works and i used to
actually be very very into dairydoc to
the extent that i was going to write my
dissertation on him um
i divide dairydes works up basically
into three periods there's a early
rigorous uh period where he's
misunderstood by the french
philosophical establishment where he's
writing speech and phenomena
on grammatology
you know
his his early essays and stuff like that
and that's pretty good stuff
and then daria starts to become you know
kind of a star and catch on and and his
work i would say declines in quality not
to say that everything is garbage
but he starts to and you know here here
you could say that that jordan peterson
and derrida kind of share something in
common except for the fact of course
jordan peterson is much more poorly read
than dairy ever was
they believed their own [ __ ] they
listened to other people about how
important their project was
and they started to
think that they were hotter [ __ ] than
they they really are and that's dario's
middle period and glob belongs to that
you know all these plays on words and
stuff like that and then we get a later
period with derrida where he starts to
turn back to
political and religious questions in
like the 1990s with things like uh
politics of friendship specters of marx
opporeas
um
you know a lot of really interesting
stuff the problem with that is that it's
not
it's not as rigorously
reworked and edited as his earlier work
so it's not quite as good but yeah glob
belongs to that middle period so
uh masak says what do you think of aoc
do you think she deserves the crap she
gets from the right no nobody deserves
the crap they get from the right i mean
the right at this point in time are a
bunch of you know
nutters and grievance people
and
self-indulgent you know jerks who
have completely abandoned any sort of uh
wish to work with other people so
being criticized by the right
anybody who sticks their neck out and
says anything worth saying is going to
be criticized by the right because
they're just a bunch of selfish [ __ ]
you know
um it's it's unfortunate but that's what
the right has turned into there isn't
there isn't really any real opposition
from within the right criticizing its
own
so until we see something like that i
wouldn't pay much attention to what they
have to say because it's nearly always
going to be just self-serving
um i think aoc is fine you know we
should have some some people who are uh
further on the left in the political
system you know the idea of having
representative democracy is not that we
have these two power blocks right um one
of whom is is seemingly totally you know
self-interested and racist and you know
obsessed with imposing hierarchy and uh
behold into all sorts of like stories
about how great things were in the past
that turn out to be you know completely
unfounded
um and then we've got you know the messy
democrats over here
um i'm you know i'm fine with with with
her um she's gonna say some dumb things
every once in a while like every single
human being on earth says dumb things
you look at the overall picture and the
overall picture is something i'm i'm
fine with
uh darth vader can philosophy and
religious faith be reconciled or even
complement each other i mean of course
because they have throughout history
this is this is a this is like a
no-brainer i mean
it's there in plato right there there is
talk about the gods in plato so
and then we could go on and on and on
there's like you know thousands of
different ways in which
philosophers theologians literary
figures have reconciled faith and
philosophy it depends on what you mean
by faith and what you mean by philosophy
so
yeah
hey mark good to see you here
um
and i'm i'm always looking for these uh
looking forward to these sessions as
well crystal crypto what are the best
arguments for god being real so what's
the difference in god being real or god
existing
i'm not sure why it's phrased
that way or what real is supposed to
mean
there's a whole host of arguments out
there there's no best argument
i mean there's an entire literature on
that so i'm not sure what you're asking
me about that for um there's you know
lots of different classifications i
think i've done plenty of videos on
people who are doing these these sort of
arguments
um so yeah i don't know what you're
looking for there
uh cork mars i watched an old video
where you criticized unionization you
probably actually miss misheard i didn't
criticize unionization at any point as
such i've criticized some kinds of
unions right so we always want to be
careful
in what we
hear and attribute to people i have the
same stances i've had for the last 20
years some unions are good some unions
are bad
it's that simple
you know i have a lot of family members
who are in unions including some unions
that i would say that on the whole are
good for them but bad for everybody else
so let's let's break this down right
to begin with let's talk about
police unions police unions are not real
unions they're really just
lobbying organizations that are set up
to protect police from consequences
they're not even the same as firefighter
unions or emt unions or something like
that police unions should go there
there's nothing good about them as far
as i can see in in their last you know
20 years of history they are on the
wrong side of just about everything so
that's that's one union that's bad
teachers unions um teachers unions can
be good teachers unions can be bad it
really depends on the union there's more
than one out there
and what they're pushing for
on the whole i would say that you know
they tend to be good in
preserving jobs and in standing against
the privatization of education which i
think is a bad move
they tend to be bad in that they
protect mediocrity right
what about trade unions uh well here
we've got to talk about whether we're
talking about sort of broad uh you know
covering lots and lots of workers
um things that would include not just
particular
trades but you know uh workers more
generally
those are in the whole pretty good i
mean they can become corrupt every once
in a while and then they got to be
cleaned up but those actually those are
the kinds of unions that want us the
things that unions are always talking
about
what about um professional unions or
craft unions like you know
ironworkers i have i have two uh family
members who are in the ironworkers
well here's where we get to something a
little bit tricky right
those are good for the ironworkers and
for their families and they their
attitude towards everybody else is screw
everybody else right they're not they're
not looking out for
anybody else and they although they
would claim to be working class
they display antagonism towards anybody
else in their trade who's not in the
union to begin with and towards other
people who are working class just watch
union workers uh you know from
ironworkers or carpenters or things like
that when they go into a restaurant and
see how they treat people like [ __ ]
they're not real
they're not there's no class solidarity
there and their union is about
protecting their jobs and their benefits
and screw everybody else so what would
you make of a union like that it's not a
good union it's actually just protecting
some people i remember when my uncle
scott who now is in the ironworker union
used to be a dry waller and the drywall
it was i think they were associated with
the carpenters they would come to his
work site and say you should hire three
of our guys for your work site he'd say
are you gonna hire three of our guys for
your work sites and they'd be like oh
no man it doesn't work that way so some
unions are basically just parasitical
right so we've got to be really careful
when we talk about unionization
i think that i'm always happy to see
things like say starbucks being
unionized or pushes to unionize amazon
or
recently you know our local two cop big
coffee chains here in in this area
colectivo and stone creek you know
they've they've got unions as well i'm
all for that sort of thing uh when it's
actually protecting people i think
unionization is a good thing when it's
just protecting privileges
for people who want a posture as being
working class when they're not really
associated with a working class then get
rid of them when they're protecting bad
cops get rid of them right so
there we go um
bro what are all the works of plato i
need to read i've got a video on a
self-directed study on plato so i'd
suggest watching that it depends on what
you want to learn right there's no
one-size-fit-all
answer for that i mean you could do
anything from getting yourself the
collected works of plato and reading it
from you know cover to cover to
setting up a curriculum for yourself
idk thoughts on the anti-psychiatry
thought or movement i i think that i
mean that's been around for a very long
time
um
i would say that you know it served its
purpose in some respects
the people these days who are really
anti-psychiatry across the board i think
are nutters
um and are often kind of dangerous um
not helpful to to other people it's sort
of like you know
the old expression throwing the baby out
with the bath water there's a lot of bad
psychiatry and counseling and psychology
and you know all these things that fit
into this spectrum of
mental health or behavioral health what
do we whatever we want to call it
psychotherapy
but we don't say oh well because we ran
into a few bad ones or because this
school over here is bad we throw it all
out that's that's a little
excessive and i would say in terms of
psychology kind of crazy isn't it
um
all right it just skipped a little bit
it looks like there's a lot more
questions
um
sana says thank you finally somebody's
saying that about peterson a lot of
people have been saying that about
peterson for many years there's actually
a reddit i think it's called enough
peterson's spam
there's lots of people out there who
recognize that that peterson is
basically a joke we actually ran
a
controversy in
stoicism today the blog that i edit uh
years back about whether peterson is or
isn't a stoic and massimo piggliucci has
a great article in there weighing in
about that taking peterson's own works
and showing how if anybody's you know
worth being called post-modernist in the
sense that peterson is using it where
it's all you know gobbily
his writings are like that i mean read
maps of meaning uh it's uh yeah it's
kind of a mess all right luke says once
i think you described yourself as a
virtue ethicist when asked about your
political disposition more than once as
a matter of fact very very consistently
i do that what can i study to learn
about virtue ethics applied in political
systems aristotle has a book called the
politics that would be a place to to
start i mean there's like an entire host
of virtue ethics stuff from ancient
philosophy plato has this book called
the republic he's got a later book
called the laws you know aristotle's
nick of mccain ethics and udemy ethics
and rhetoric all have to say stuff about
justice and society and politics
i mean there's there's a whole host of
stuff out there so
i would just you know um look you know
google virtue ethics and politics and
see what comes up there's going to be a
ton of things that will will come up
uh max says are there any
works and philosophers you would
recommend who discuss the topic of
stress and anxiety again ancient virtue
ethics does right they won't necessarily
use the word stress or anxiety although
epictetus is agonia gets translated as
anxiety but they are talking about and
delving deeply into the question of why
we feel fear or
why we worry about stuff so you've got
you know vast traditions the platonic
all the way through neoplatonus stuff
you've got the aristotelian you've got
the stoic you've got the epicureans
you've got um even the the skeptics
whether pyronian or academic you've got
eclectics like cicero you've got all
sorts of people going into the uh
encounter with with you know jewish and
christian and later muslim thought you
know um there's there's literally you
know
hundreds of philosophers you could look
at the existentialists also discuss it
kierkegaard has an entire book the
concept of anxiety
anxiety plays a major role in
heidegger's work so there's lots and
lots of people and a lot of that
actually ended up trickling into
psychotherapy
in one way or another if you look at its
origins you know existential
psychotherapy
uh obviously influenced by the
existentialists stoics uh stoic uh
thought you know uh important for rebt
and cbt and um you know these these
origins of the cognitive
movement
so there's there's there's a lot out
there um
uh let's see here
sid says in terms of learning formal
logic would you recommend reading prior
and posterior
analytics by aristotle or taking a
modern course why not do both
i mean you know it's
nothing in philosophy is something that
you should just
master and then move on from
um why why wouldn't you want to see what
aristotle actually has to say about this
stuff and you wouldn't just look by the
way at the
prior and posterior analytics you'd also
look at the on statistical refutations
you look at the categories and you look
at the topics because all of these deal
with the broad topic of logic the stoics
themselves had a logic um the magarians
were interested in it and we know a
little bit about their their points of
view
there's all sorts of medieval writers
there's early modern writers there's you
know later 19th century writers like jon
stewart mill
and then we get what we call modern
logic
which is basically you know late 19th
and 20th century stuff and there's a lot
of cool stuff in there too
you know
you could you could read wittgenstein's
uh early tractatus and you'd be like oh
i see what he's doing he's basically
doing logic and then irving kopi was a
really important guy
um in in the movement and uh you know
there's there's all sorts of
other cool stuff that's connected with
it
like um
you know logics that are
non-binary and you know fuzzy logics and
um there's uh applications of logic to
other things like you know
necessity and possibility by the way
some of that stuff was going on in
antiquity so
there's like a vast field out there and
then you know logic kind of bleeds over
into
critical thinking slash informal logic
and into rhetoric so
there's i mean you could have a massive
uh reading list and research project to
go with that so i don't think it's a uh
single thing it's sort of a both and
there
quark mars do you agree with the utopian
socialist idea of charles fourier
that the world would be a better place
if all people were trained for several
jobs which they could move between at
their their leisure
yes and no i mean i think that some
people
may not want to have
different jobs or may not be suited for
different jobs if you think about uh
people who are are seriously um
you know developmentally disabled maybe
they can find something that's enjoyable
and meaningful and socially productive
and that's good enough
i i don't know that we i mean the the
point of fact is that these days
um it is becoming rare that we stay in
one job forever like people did you know
50 years ago
um
but i think a lot of people
want to have a a
if it's not just one single job at least
to stay in a single field you know like
if you train as a nurse maybe you don't
want to be a nurse forever
but you probably still want to remain
within something connected to the
medical field right so i i think it very
much depends on disposition but it i
mean ideally
we would all have the
chance to choose something so we're not
just simply forced into the employment
that we have
all right rough uh roughly bumble any
thoughts or advice on when one knows
it's one christian's duty to forgive yet
can't seem to
uh but can't help but seem so
inauthentic to one who is in one's heart
well there isn't a duty to forgive
so there's there are injunctions right
if you think about the sermon on the
mount
or other um places
we're told we shouldn't forgive that
doesn't mean that it's some sort of
strict duty that every single time we
have to forgive and um
we also don't have to forgive
immediately right
um it may take a lot of time to forgive
people who have
been abusive towards us for a long time
who or who deny the fact that they've
done something wrong and try to you know
project it on to us or blame it on
somebody else
um
so i i want to say that to begin with
you know i mean it's better if we
forgive and it's not just a christian
thing by the way aristotle says that the
uh characteristic of the person
who
has a good temper is to be forgiving
right in in the greek and there's an
entire literature on forgiveness outside
of christianity
but
you know
it's it's something that
requires a you know less across the
board this is what you must do and a
more specified approach there's lots of
different situations and it's probably
i mean this is this is also there's
another interesting point there's a lot
of pressure and it's almost always
placed on those who are in the more
vulnerable position
you know within christian cultures
um particularly catholic and evangelical
cultures man it's it's it can sometimes
be overwhelming when everybody around
you is like you know
they're really not so bad it's bothering
us that you're not forgiving them and
they like want you to forgive somebody
who's a complete [ __ ] an abuser and
has a whole history
of that you know when when jesus says
blessed be the peacemakers there's a lot
of fake peacemakers out there and
they're not blessed right they're
actually contributing to the problem so
i you know i feel you when you talk
about the inauthentic you know when you
compel forgiveness it's not authentic
forgiveness you know like if you tell
your kids oh you know you have to
forgive this thing that somebody did at
school like imagine this for example
you're being bullied and or your kid is
being bullied and you say to them oh you
know jesus says turn the other cheek and
you should you should pray for your
oppressors
that's actually
counterproductive i mean the best thing
to be to say i think would be wow this
these kids are real jerks and i'm gonna
go talk to the principal and see what i
can do about this so there's agency
involved and you shouldn't have to put
up with this sort of thing
but
it might also be good for you to think
about ways in which you can
understand why they're such screw-ups
and to be able to forgive them not
something that you owe to them
but something that would be good for you
so you're not you know playing out
revenge fantasies in your mind all day
long
or you know
putting yourself at risk for
um
getting in in
fights with you know other people or
turning into an abuser yourself right so
i think yeah there's
i don't know if this is particularly
helpful i mean basically what i'm saying
is don't feel like you're obligated to
to forgive people forgiveness is a gift
right and it's something that's not just
for them
or for whoever else is telling you you
have to forgive but it's it's for
you you know to be able to move on the
in the the
gospels forgiveness is tied to this verb
aphemi which means to let go right
not exactly the same thing as
in the other greek terms but it's
connected
um
sid says thanks for the response that's
a good mindset to have in terms of
learning i read the categories but was
questioning whether or not to continue i
mean
you know you can do multiple things
they're not going to
they're not going to like keep you from
they're not going to necessarily
interfere with each other right it's not
like having
one kind of music on in in in the room
and then turning on another kind of
music or watching two tv shows at the
same time right um so yeah
all right let's uh
see what else we've got
uh santa says is it okay that meeting
you is on my bucket list uh sure i mean
you can put whatever you want on on a
bucket list that's that's up to you
um i
you know this is kind of interesting so
i'm going to take this in a little bit
of a different way
i have gotten to meet some people over
the years and in some cases form
friendships or at least you know
collegial relationships with people that
i would consider to be the rock stars of
my
my field
philosophy
i think the first um
[Music]
the first person i met like that where i
had that kind of like holy [ __ ] it's
that person
reaction was uh kate rogers a great
anselm scholar
who uh spoke at the
she was the plenary speaker at the
second saint anselm conference
and
she and i got to be you know um
i would i wouldn't say friends but
friend lee over time and and she's given
me you know
comments on my work and asked me for
comments on hers which was kind of a big
honor and then um obviously alistair
mcintyre that you know i got to study
with him
uh one summer and then you know we we
had uh i'd you know meet up with him at
conferences and stuff like that or see
him when i was at notre dame
um
chris gill you know uh who i'm connected
with in the the modern stoicism
um
organization you know it's it's really
cool when you when you read people and
you're like wow this is great stuff you
know and then you get to meet him and
same thing with like some of the people
who've been stoic on speakers like julia
anas you know great uh virtue ethics
person
or uh margaret graver whose book
stoicism and emotion is is really
quite awesome or anthony long you know
meeting him that was another rock star
kind of thing so
you know and it's always cool to find
out too that these
i mean i have met some some academics
who are kind of pricks frankly but all
the people that i'm naming there they're
all they're all cool people you know so
that's that's
i don't have a bucket list but i guess
meeting some of those people could have
been on my bucket list
all right sg and the brothers karamazov
in the grand inquisitor chapter when the
grand inquisitor describes his utopian
social structure to me it seems similar
to plato's ideal structure what are your
thoughts
no i'd say they're they're disconnected
i mean plato if you read the republic
everybody is doing the work that that is
suited for them and it's in order to
make them actually happy and happy as a
society happy as a
group and it's also the second best city
it's not the truly utopian city which is
described earlier in book two
and then rejected by glaucon and
adamantis
now the grain inquisitor is doing
something
rather different and and it's it's
dealing with a different problematic
than plato is formulating the problem of
human freedom
is it completely different no but
it's arranged in in different ways and
the grand inquisitor is saying listen i
mean here's where there there's some
similarity and there's a similarity to
1984 and there's a similarity to i mean
every other
kind of utopian thing out there
somebody's in charge and it kind of
sucks to be in charge right
there's a great short story called the
marching morons
which is dealing with a similar thematic
um there's like an in-group who knows
what's going on and then there's all the
dummies who have basically
lost their freedom
but they are happier as a result you
know
uh sade i'm becoming a philosophy
teacher at high school if you want to
give some advice what will they be
well
um
hang on for a rough ride because i mean
pre-covid teaching high schoolers not
something i'd want to do i've done guest
lectures in high schools you know and i
remember being a high school student
and
yeah it's that's they're they're a tough
crowd you know hormone driven very about
you know prestige status lots of anxiety
because they don't know where they're
going in life getting all sorts of other
bad advice from from adults like other
teachers
so
i would say i mean if i had to give
advice
don't measure
your success
in teaching by anything that you see
immediately presented in front of you
because you never know
what sort of seeds you're planting
and a lot of your students might not be
in the right you know receptive
whatever you want to call it position
mood
time of life to to really benefit at
that moment from what you're teaching
them but i i can think of a few
uh teachers that i had who made an
incredible mark on me much more than
they they would ever have suspected and
you may have some students like that as
well
so when you start to feel discouraged or
anything
just keep on trucking
and tell yourself that you don't have to
do anything perfect you just have to do
good enough and good enough is is still
good
all right um
zeno do you like to study mythology if
so what is your favorite what have you
learned from it
i mean i don't study mythology
i
i read classic works that reference
myths
but
mythology as such is not like a object
of study
for me and i don't i don't have a
favorite i mean i find
um the stories that are told you know
all sorts of ones quite interesting and
i'm i'm mostly interested in them not
just as a good story but what what they
tell us about like a society and its
mindset or
you know
things like that
riley wah what do you think of hegel's
critique of stoicism
what does christianity offer over
stoicism or anything
well i think hegel's critique of
stoicism
is um off base in part because he got
stoicism wrong but he got stoicism wrong
in a way that a lot of people in his
time were getting stoicism wrong
[Music]
he views it largely as a withdrawal from
the world from a world that is hostile
and unfair and irrational into
kind of a realm of
imaginary
rationality where you've got the
rational the good the true you've got
these these things that are you know
kind of transcendentals
and they are within your sphere of
agency right um
and i think
the way that some people
take on stoicism and i'm sure hegel met
some people who self-identified as
stoics who behaved that way
yeah his critique is on point um and his
critique is on point with respect to any
sort of idealistic thing like that i
mean and it could apply to many forms of
christianity too where people are polly
anish and they don't actually look at
the world that they're engaged with or
the families that they're they're
involved in with hegel there's always
this you cannot avoid
the the real the vehicle the
you know that's that's the german term
for it the actual
all ideas have to be engaged
with actuality hegel's form of idealism
is very very practical and
insofar as there are stoics as there
were in his time as there were
in the past as we know epictetus
criticizes them
and as there are today in the you know
modern and traditional stoic movements
for whom stoicism is essentially a way
of withdrawing from the world and
keeping yourself safe his critique is
right insofar as stoicism is more than
that which
uh just a close you know reading of the
texts one going through them once would
indicate to be the case
um and then thinking about the fact that
stoics have committed themselves very
clearly to political causes and social
causes
you can tell that hegel's got things
wrong and the question then is well how
did he get things wrong like that and
there's another story to be told which
is that in the in the 19th century and
really this runs all the way into the
20th century in many respects there is
this centering on on plato and aristotle
as like this is what real greek
philosophy is which is not the way
things were in the past by the way
it's kind of a new thing a new schtick
that they put out there and why because
that was identified with the greek
city-state the time of the city-state
and then hellenistic philosophy ah it's
all kind of derivative it's you know
it's for a uh um you know a subject who
doesn't fit into a city-state but is
just kind of lost in this this vast
cosmos or in the in the empire
and again maybe there were some people
like that but that's that's a misreading
of hellenistic philosophy right so
all right um
is it usma x what do you think about
natalie sir
uh
sarah and the meta roman who met a novel
right um i don't think anything of it i
haven't
even
heard her name
mentioned since i was in an aesthetics
class
back in um
grad school and i don't know enough to
say anything competently
um eb what do you think of the early
hegel his early works are quite
different than the phenomenology or
later works the phenomenology is still
early hegel right
but yeah i mean thinkers grow
i don't find the early i i i did find
the early hegel interesting much earlier
in my career
i don't really find him that interesting
now i'd rather read the phenomenology or
you know much later works like the
uh philosophy of right
than
try to trace out the you know
the path that he's going on i just don't
don't find it that that interesting
um armond what's your stance on the
problem of the many i don't know what
the problem of the many means that could
that could be a whole bunch of different
things if i want to joke around we could
say that's many um are you talking about
the fact that there is plurality um
that seems to me to be a brute fact that
we're
uh faced with so i don't see it as a
problem
um
matthew are you familiar with the work
of ian mcgill christ i am not so
but this this hypothesis that brain
hemisphere lateralization has had a huge
impact on philosophy and the culture at
large sounds entirely implausible to me
um any sort of reductive i've got the
key to everything i i'm like yeah
been there done that so many times
throughout history the odds of anything
like that explaining complex matters
like philosophy is extremely low
um you know
i'm not a reductionist so i'm very i'm
very skeptical of reductionists
um
eb what do you think of the of gaston
bachelorette he seems like a truly
underappreciated thinker i haven't read
him since grad school either and
um
[Music]
i never found anything i thought that i
thought was really really interesting in
it which is why i haven't read him uh
since
he he could be underappreciated
so many else are um so yeah
made of clay well this is an interesting
one i keep meeting people who hate
nihilism to an unhealthy level when they
believe they see it in others
why do people feel a need to repair some
damage that nihilism has done i mean it
seems like it's some unavoidable step in
a realist conviction rather than
something buried by proving something
well i would say odds are that the
people who are like so anti-nihilist are
probably themselves nihilists in some
some respect and they hate that aspect
of themselves and they're horribly
afraid that maybe you know there is no
meaning or anything like that
secure confident people don't behave
that way you know
um
it could also be that
they don't really mean nihilism to go
back to like the jordan peterson thing
you know if peterson talks about
um postmodern marxism or anything like
that you can be like well this guy
doesn't know what the hell he's talking
about or what the words actually refer
to
uh he just hates other people and fears
them for some some other reason right
there's something else that they're
responding to that they don't they don't
have a good idea about the same thing
with people who are like oh you know the
communists and socialists in congress
are coming there's no communist or
socialist in congress
you know um
not in any real sense so if you're if
you're throwing those words out there
it's a sign of insecurity
kind of an illiteracy
you know opportunism fear on on your own
part so these people who are like hating
nihilism do they really hate nihilism do
they really
diagnose nihilism in other people
probably not it's other things that
they're they're responding to you know
um
there's a question from idk can a
genuine socialist communist movement
thrive in the u.s given the fact that a
large number of u.s citizens has such a
negative reactionary views about it
probably not um
i mean even if you took that away i
don't know that
that it would thrive or that we would
necessarily want a communist i mean i
can go along with a lot of socialist
ideas i mean being a socialist basically
means recognizing that we live in a
society and that we shouldn't turn
everything over to you know mechanisms
of individual opportunism and greed and
stuff like that and people should pay
their taxes fairly so that we can
actually like you know distribute
benefits in fair and rational ways i
don't have a beef with that any more
than i have a beef with feminism if
feminism means you know we should have a
society in which men and women and
anybody else has equal opportunities to
do things and sometimes that means
tinkering around with things and writing
historical imbalances those those to me
are rational
uh ways of looking at things that any
virtue ethicist would in fact be in
favor of um as a rational person but
yeah i mean the well has been so
poisoned against
uh the word socialism and communism
since when i was a little kid um
by and by people who you know either
didn't know better and they're
responsible for their own ignorance or
did know better and we're just using it
as a
you know a dog whistle so
all right um
dylan why do you consider that to lose
is less rigorous when working with
qatari i don't think i've ever used the
word less rigorous
he's certainly less interesting to me
and i think he does better work when
he's on his own than when he's with
qatar he really enjoyed working with
qatari and seemed to prefer
to work with qatari i just think the
works are better um i i think that you
know there's a lot of loosey-goosey
you know invocations of things not that
there aren't some in his other works but
i mean take uh anti-oedipus and put it
up against some of his historical works
like the fold on leibniz and you can see
the difference or logic of sense
you know
um
to me that
that just seems kind of apparent i think
a lot of people really like the you know
freewheeling
all these jargon things getting thrown
in that they get with the lose and
guitar he works but they're
they're trying to get something
different out of a philosophical book
than i guess i am um
oh
here's a question from costello
i'm six months into my phd suddenly
every subject appears more interesting
than my current topic do i have to
sacrifice my passion for a topic in
order to peruse it academically
so a couple things to say this is
entirely normal and it will not just
happen during your phd time it will
happen while you're trying to write
another book down the line or organize a
class we're always distracted by the
greener grass or whatever other metaphor
we want to use you know when we're
supposed to be working on this thing we
want to work on this other thing so
that's that's common um and and you
don't have to let it you know make you
feel like there's something wrong with
you it's it's just what what happens
quite often i mean there are some people
who don't run into that and it's usually
because they only have like one real big
set of thoughts in their head and that's
that's all they're going to work on
but if you find a lot of things
interesting you're going to be drawn in
different directions
six months into your phd program you
don't actually have to have a project i
know a lot of people tell you you do but
you don't you don't have to decide what
your project is until you're
working on your dissertation first
you've got to do your coursework
and i mean if you're an american
university right things are a little bit
different at brit universities where
they're very hands-off and you don't do
coursework for your phd but i'm going to
talk about like american stuff you do a
lot of coursework two years worth at
least i did i did three because i
thought i'm going to take as many
classes as i can
while i've still got funding
and then you um pass your
prelims or whatever else you have to do
in place of that a lot of places don't
have prelims these days then you write a
prospectus and now is here where you're
actually settling on a topic and you're
saying i'm gonna write on nietzsche
on this topic here i'm going to write
something about the history of the
ontological arguments from anselm onward
to kant right and now you've actually
got a project that you're being tied to
because you're issuing this promissory
note of a prospectus that a committee
will look at and give you feedback on
and then you write the dissertation but
you do not have to come in
and have you know
at the very beginning or six months in
or a year in you don't have to have a
project that is like your project it's
okay for that to change
um and some people may give you a hard
time about it but that's because they
that's their problem right that's that's
not really your problem your advisor
might want you to stick to something but
that's your advisor's problem too and
they're doing that because they want to
make life easier for themselves or they
want your project to fit into their
project right
whether they're going to cannibalize
your work or whether they're just going
to say oh look at my brilliant protege
or whatever else they're going to get
out of it but it's it's your
dissertation and it's your phd you do
whatever the hell you want because
you're the one paying the bills
even if you're getting funding you're
the one who earned that funding so it's
it's up to you you know
uh eb what would early marks of center
done if you lived through the pandemic
like us i don't know you know probably
if marx were here in the present he'd
have all sorts of
interesting things to say just like if
aristotle did
it it's almost impossible to make
predictions
um about great thinkers just throwing
them into a different situation like
well what if marx was in a band with
david bowie would he have played the
drums or would he have played the bass
because he wouldn't have been david
bowie singing who knows
so
all right um
[Music]
damon forbes la police lobby to get 3.1
billion yeah this is the the story of
police uh unions we were talking about
unionization earlier that's what they do
all over the place
um
and it's you know it's kind of
unfortunate but
we got to break the police unions right
um
riley do you think it's valuable to read
hagel as an educator or philosopher of
education i know he inspired the saint
louis hegelians and was himself a school
headmaster for some time
i mean
if you think about
the phenomenology and the science of
logic
there's bits and pieces
of them that i guess you could use for
coming together you know some philosophy
of education hegel doesn't provide you
with a philosophy of education
in any particular work so you'd really
really have to work at it
i don't know if it's worth doing it you
know i don't know what you would get out
of turning him into a philosopher of
education i mean the the person who's
who's influenced by hegel who's probably
most important in that respect is john
dewey right because he was he was a
hegelian early on
um and he still you know
retained some things uh from him
but yeah i don't know i i don't think
there's probably some literature out
there if you look but i've never
actually looked into that
um
[Music]
let's see
rt whitby says by being a good
philosopher poet and wrestler didn't
plato disprove his own belief he could
only be good at one thing
yeah or maybe he was being ironic when
he suggested that or maybe he was saying
that you can do that some people can do
more than one thing i mean i i wouldn't
be so qui quite so rigid about that
right
um eb nature low tegel hegel subsumed
the singular individual in their will
under a totalizing system blah blah blah
blah blah right yeah i mean
that's a nice set of sound bites about
hegel but that doesn't really map on to
hegel when you read them um
so
all right um
sam i've heard it said that heidegger's
philosophy owes quite a large debt to
henry bergson's work do you think this
is true nah not really
i mean we we know who the
the sources are
because
you know
heidegger tells us
this is here's an idea from kierkegaard
here's an idea from aristotle here's an
idea from mock shaler you know his
contemporary phenomenologist i i don't
think heidegger is getting much from
bergson frankly
um
let's see mr poncho when you took a
reading class with the classics
department did you read anything outside
of philosophy
what has been an interesting work you
read or liked to read in greek or latin
i i did two uh well actually i did three
reading classes so we you know
first we have like our first year greek
thing right
and there
no i actually took four reading classes
first you're greek you learn all the
things that you need to learn you you
start learning how to how to solve the
problems you're going to encounter like
where do you go in smythe the grammar to
find things how do you use the lexicon
effectively
then you start reading things and in my
first reading class we read
three short pieces we read
a speech by
lysius
we read plato's credo and we read
lucian's true history
and then following that we had another
class where we read
not the totality but parts of herodotus
is history and then i did independent
studies
where i read um
with rick williams the symposium over an
entire semester and then with brian
johnson
um
the um
aristotle's nick mccain ethics we didn't
read the totality of it i think there
were some things we skipped oh and i
also did a yeah actually i did a reading
of the
odyssey so i took quite a few classes
with the classics department now that i
think about it
so
yeah i mean
i i'm i'm mostly using my
greek or latin just as a tool
for making sense out of the authors that
i teach or i'm writing on though
jacob stanley says currently reading the
varieties of religious experience by
william james if you've read any
thoughts tips i should keep in mind
while reading i was in a car crash uh
okay
james in the varieties of religious
experience does a lot of long citation
of other people so keeping track of what
james himself thinks and what his
um
raw material thinks
is quite important i would say
um
you know you want to also keep in mind
that james is using the philosophical
and psychological vocabulary of his day
there's a lot of references to other
thinkers as well in that
i i like james myself
[Music]
i
i don't buy everything that he has to
say but i find him a useful interlocutor
all right um
darth vader
what are your thoughts on
anti-philosophy badu characterizes saint
paul nature pascal rousseau kierkegaard
wittgenstein lecon to name a few of the
anti-philosophers
anybody can call anybody an
anti-philosopher once they've decided
what philosophy consists in so i don't
find the notion of anti-philosophy
particularly interesting because it
always ends up becoming another way of
doing philosophy
so
boris grace also writes about that as
well he's actually got a book called
anti-philosophy so
you know what's cool is sometimes is
that it brings thinkers to light who we
norma normally wouldn't get to like
groyce talks about lev shestoff in a
chapter who i think is a very underrated
philosopher
um
but you know this whole philosophy
versus anti-philosophy philosophy itself
is so incredibly diverse
that it's uh
you always have to specify what you mean
by philosophy
miles roth what do you think of the
works of joseph campbell second rate um
that's that's my view on him interesting
worth reading sometimes but second rate
um i i don't i don't take the hero's
journey seriously or stuff like that um
jib far maybe
any thoughts on the metaverse or the
development of virtual reality in
general and its potential social
consequences we're already in virtual
reality i'm talking to you
all over the world from my apartment
here in milwaukee through this interface
and you know you're hearing me and
seeing me in a variety of different ways
and responding to each other we've been
living in a partially virtual state for
a long time the fact that we put goggles
on or that there's like a map
just adds some new wrinkles to it i
would say
and um i i don't know about the
metaverse because i haven't explored it
um anything that would be tied with with
facebook to me seems like a a bad idea
um
[Music]
and i i don't know you know sooner or
later
we think about the the old cyberpunk
stuff right like william gibson who is
so imaginatively trying to figure out
what's this world going to be like and
and the internet the way it is now looks
very different than what it is but one
thing that's that's definitely there
are people who um because of their lives
not being the way they are that they
want them to be spend so much time
jacked in right as is the word that
gibson used just like uh you know living
out fantasies and stuff like that i mean
i get advertisements for like this vast
array of games that clearly people are
are playing
in my amazon or you know google or stuff
like that i don't know that much about
it cause i haven't explored these games
because who the hell has time for that
but uh clearly there's a lot of people
you know
tapped into that but i mean it's been
like that for a long time people who are
obsessed with nfl football and engaging
in fantasy leagues and memorizing stats
and you know going to sports bars and
like keeping their eyes glued to the
screen
they were living a virtual life back in
uh the 90s right um so
there's a lot of
uh ways in which
i mean i'll put it to you this way we're
at a point now where
we're totally sucked in you know we do
still have real things
but
um you know we we are pretty tapped into
this this uh
digital reality
all right um
will says i'd like to thank you for your
great detailed videos i wouldn't be in
my final semester of my philosophy
degree without you oh that's very nice
to read i'm glad i'm glad the videos
have been
useful
so
all right uh useless projects do you
think the stoics and sigmund freud would
disagree on what causes someone to have
depression overcoming it and curing it
for what parts do you think they
disagree on or agree
freud doesn't have a
you know freud is really talking about a
lot of other things besides depression
freudians have have explored it more
um freud very often doesn't think that
there's one single ideology that covers
every single person who's ever had a
malady you that's why you do depth
psychology right that's why you
find out what what happened in this
person's life
a lot of that is very compatible with
the stoics i would say you know um if
you're if you're stoic and you want to
figure out why you're
having the the feelings that you do and
and you you know start delving into your
unconscious or you know whatever you
want to call them implicit thought
processes and their connection with
affectivity
it might actually help to have somebody
not necessarily psychoanalyze you but
have a
um
have somebody else to work with right
a dialogue partner so
and it's not as if there's a single
stoic take on this word that we have
depression which they weren't using back
then
um so it's you know
it's it's a little bit difficult to
compare this i would say
um
[Music]
giga chad mesh what are your research
interests at the moment are publications
the only point for research interests
no i mean
i'm
[Music]
you know
shooting videos on things i'm interested
in and holding events and you know doing
podcasts and giving interviews and
teaching classes and you know there's
all sorts of
things i mean my research interests are
not radically new and they are very you
know diverse
but
you know i do i do a lot of other kinds
of writing as well media is is a place
where you can find my more popular
writing so
yeah
all right
huh flight of icarus
what is good literature to read for
youth from foster care for the orphan um
[Music]
you know i'm i'm adopted
and i was fortunate in that i was
adopted into
a a good family that had some challenges
but was overall quite loving and
thoughtful and and made the right
decisions unfortunately my adopted dad
died
pretty young he was only 36 and i was 11
and my adopted mom died when she was
53
actually this is the the month uh that
she she died in towards the end of the
month
um
i was 29 at the time so
one of the books that i found useful is
just called on being adopted
now will that have useful stuff for
somebody in foster care
i don't know it's been a while since i
looked at it but i mean part of the the
issues that you go through
is like you know figuring out who you
are
how you fit into things i mean i'm
fortunate in that i was adopted into a
family both in terms of our little
nuclear family and then in terms of our
larger
we're basically on my mom's side of
ethnographically a clan you know uh
where there's like
all these different branches to the
family that trace back to mamey and pape
you know and and our ancestors that go
all the way back to uh pierre the fifth
in 18
1638 coming to quebec
um there's actually a book about the guy
called the fave delemaries
and i was never my point in bringing
this up is in my little family and in
the larger family
i was always known to be adopted and i
was never treated differently
than
biological
children
that's often not the case in foster care
right
so i don't know i i don't
it's something i've never looked into
other than stuff about adoption so the
orphan i mean
yeah
i know what that's like in part
um
so yeah all right uh
santa do you have any plans to change
your job at some point it's obvious that
you're passionate about your thing if so
yes does it have anything to do with not
feeling fulfilled or totally different
reasons
um
i i probably will continue teaching for
milwaukee institute of art design as an
adjunct
for
as long as they want me to teach because
it's a great gig they actually pay the
best out of any of the places that i've
i've taught as an adjunct
they treat students and faculty very
very well the
administration is accountable and
transparent
and
my expertise is respected and valued so
that'll continue on i will probably not
continue teaching for other
institutions in the future unless they
make it worth my while you know um i've
taught for marquette i've taught from
milwaukee area technical college i still
currently teach for carthage college
um
i i don't know that i mean marquette
isn't hiring anybody anyway because
they're in financial mess that they
created themselves but
i don't know that i want to keep
teaching that much
i'll probably continue doing the kind of
client-based work that i have with
tutorials and
philosophical counseling clients and
consulting gigs and stuff like that i'd
like to do more public speaking but
kovit is you know frankly a little bit
of an impediment to that right
um
i want to do more more writing you know
publish some more books
uh either
using amazon self-publishing so i don't
have to go through the [ __ ]
rigmarole of an academic press or one of
the big trade publishers or or maybe
i'll work with someone on some things
you know and i've got online classes
that i i need to put more effort into
bringing out and selling to people
but yeah this is this is more or less
what i want to be doing i want to be
taking ideas from philosophy and
presenting them to others
and helping people to make their lives
better using it so
yeah
all right um
one two three four how do we oh i get it
one two three four how do we develop our
ability to make distinctions
by doing it a lot and screwing it up a
lot and studying other people who do it
there's no like cut and dried method for
it
it's sort of like you know you want to
play soccer get in there and start
kicking the ball around and
experimenting and you know watching
games and then taking pointers from from
other people and you know you just get
better as you as you go on and do it so
michael says are you still working on a
publication about the stoic saying live
according to nature yeah not the stoic
saying but rather the stoic concept
because it covers a wide
range
um am i still working on a book about it
yeah
book projects are going slow
um can you talk about what this means
some yeah it's very complicated i have
an entire video on it a talk that i gave
a couple years back so i would just you
know google sadler stoic nature and see
what comes up it's about an hour long so
i'm not going to take that much time
here
um
[Music]
shrey says how mimesis and diegasis make
people compare contrast aristotle and
plato i don't even know what that means
i know what each of those words mean but
that's that doesn't help me out
um
all right noah are you aware of any
serious attempt to digitally reformat
and represent philosophy like graph
visualization sure that's been going on
for decades
um
[Music]
i mean google it you know if so can you
please point me towards the people
fields books it's there have been
infographics out there for
for a long time um
so that that's not something i think i
need to work on
the unnoticeable what is the most
influential idea in all of western
philosophy there is none there's no one
single idea that is the most influential
and anybody who tries to tell you that
there is one
probably is is uh got some sort of
agenda right there you got to ask why
are they why are they claiming this one
is the one
uh peter do you see something
philosophically interesting in martial
arts for example the greek notion of the
agon
the greek notion of the agon is not
something specifically martial arts
oriented but involves any sort of
contest so you have rhetorical agons
have you ever watched combat sports yeah
but i don't find it that interesting
frankly um
so
yeah i mean you can find something
philosophically interesting in some
martial arts particularly if they have
some sort of philosophical undergirding
i think a lot of people learn some
watered-down philosophy just so they can
like say that what they're doing is
philosophical i mean
and we can say the same thing about yoga
right you know people are like oh yoga
is such a spiritual doctor and i'll be
like cool what do you think about the uh
yoga sutras by pat and jolly pot what
and i'll be like yeah you don't know a
damn thing about yoga then i guess and
it's history um you know there's there's
some serious stuff there and then
there's some some less interesting
more superficial stuff there
um
[Music]
do i take a position on the free will
debate this is from sat are you
compatibilist libertarian no free will
yeah so i take two positions one is a
meta position
the meta position is be really really
clear about what you mean by free will
if you're gonna you know say anything
about it
because otherwise you're probably
arguing at cross purposes with with
people
and then the other thing i'm i'm
essentially a compatibilist
but you know the interesting thing about
compatibilism is always
how does it actually
work you know
um how do you put it together
uh alexey what's your familiarity with
interest in care ethics or loving
perception i've actually done classes
and have videos on on care ethics so my
familiarity is
pretty high i guess you'd say
[Laughter]
let's see sylvester what do you think
the role of psychology in the 21st
century it's not a role it's a whole
bunch of roles i suppose right
um just as with there's there's no one
single
role for philosophy in the 21st century
there's going to be a whole bunch of
roles for
any particular thing
um
oh here's an interesting one
gene marco
what do you think uh the future of
architecture would be could it be a
complete artificial intelligence
takeover
so
i don't think that we're gonna see too
many fields that are completely taken
over by artificial intelligence but i
think we'll see a lot where artificial
intelligence
comes to play more and more of a role
it's interesting that you bring up
architect because you know aristotle in
nick mccain ethics book
book one talks about the architect the
architect tone right certain arts are
architect tony k
is the word we get architect from
meaning the master you know the before
we talked about architects we talked
about master builders and the master
builder is the one who determines all
the stuff that filters down to the
other levels and aristotle actually says
political science hey politike
the organization of society is the
architect
episteme the the archetectonic
science or discipline
and so architecture is one of those
things where we're probably going to
have quite a lot of artificial
intelligence doing certain tasks and
then the architect or architectural team
oversees them and gives them inputs and
modifies them at certain points you know
when it comes to architecture as a field
i don't have much to say because it's
not something that i actually study or
have a lot to say about
um
[Music]
xenovalea have you read the society the
spectacle what are your thoughts
um
i mean that's ghee to board right yeah
of course i've read him
i
i've never found him that interesting
really he is i mentioned this um you
know because my wife studied at european
graduate school he's kind of a big deal
there they they like to talk about him
quite a bit
all right um
margin says do you see any value in
existential absurdist kamu kierkegaard
philosophy for
modern times in which the ur insect ir
reconcilable disconnect theme is a
recurring pattern to explain current
events covet 19. i don't think um
i don't think chemi or kierkegaard
explain
current events having to do with covet
19 but
and uh kierkegaard i i mean i guess you
could call him an absurdist and that he
thinks the absurd is important kamu
thinks obviously though if you've read
the myth of symphysis that um
kierkegaard does the wrong thing with
the absurd right has to shut off as does
jasper's
these people that he calls
existentialists
obviously i see value in their work or i
wouldn't be doing videos on them and you
know teaching them in my classes
so yeah
uh kirkland what do you think of the
competition between the u.s and china
russia where do you think that's headed
i don't know where it's headed i mean i
can tell you this we've pissed away
so much of our resources on
um
the the military and we haven't really
gotten the kind of uh
payoff i guess you could say
that
we should have from it
and we're never going to get that money
back and
instead we allowed our infrastructure
and our social structure and our
education system and all sorts of other
things to
you know basically fall apart and and
become you know very uh
problematic
in parts i mean the good news is that
russia is in no better shape
china may pose some real problems you
know they are going to pass us up
economically
um they clearly do want to build up
their military they they have hegemonic
uh pretensions i think russia is pretty
much
you know a has-been
um
[Music]
but you know
we've got a real adversary in china and
uh nobody over the last 20 years has
really seemed to want other than you
know posturing you know to really want
to do much uh about it so
um
ally own inc i guess what are your
thoughts on veganism if you're not a
vegan what is your
ethical justifications for being for not
being one i mean facetiously i'd say my
ethical justification for not being one
is that i'm not a pretentious [ __ ]
who wants to get into everybody else's
business and constantly lecture them and
you could say well that's unfair well
think about how many vegans you know
we're like that
my view is that we should try to move as
much as possible towards a um
you know a plant-based diet and we
should end factory farming
it is possible to harvest meat ethically
i mean that's that's who we purchase
from we pay quite a bit more for that
but um you know
that it is possible i think i think a
lot of vegans are very extreme in how
they treat things and they're not you
know proportional at all
if you
just don't eat meat for one day from the
vegan perspective that's just as bad as
you know not eating meat
this is as bad as eating meat all the
time no it's not it's actually it's an
improvement right
um i think there's a lack of perspective
quite often
and
um
you know sort of counterproductive
centurious
uh a lot of the time so that's that's my
view and i've known a lot of [ __ ]
vegans over the course of my my life
right
uh the worst ones are the ones who have
just become a vegan right
uh
wasteland radio best uh method for
combating the demiurge i wouldn't say
that here because you know you might be
listening right
um
ben says just read kamu for the first
time my friends all think he's the worst
[Laughter]
i actually agreed with some of it when
you read kamu would you say the scariest
parts were the parts you were agreed
with no i because camus is actually not
particularly scary
or uh and i mean the thinking is the
worst the worst among what i mean have
your friends read uh some some
philosophers who aren't very good
these these hyperbolic reactions that
people have
uh are you know you always got to ask
what do they actually mean by that right
all right uh i just jumped a little bit
let's see what we got we have a lot of
questions here um i think i i may have
to uh
we're not going to get to all of them
aaron uh mcnally says how do you think
about the concept of god
um
never fully right i mean whatever
concept we if god exists and god is
remotely like what the
you know what's called the grand
tradition of philosophical engagement
with god
um
looks thinks god looks like we're only
getting like a tiny little window into
it i mean read anselm's pro slogan which
begins at you know at the very beginning
with you know uh a prayer to god to help
him
you know strip away some of the messed
up parts of of his
his soul's eye so he can actually see
things rightly then it goes into what
people call the ontological argument
that's not really an ontological
argument as such like descartes or you
know kant's caricatures of them and we
find out that god is greater that then
which nothing greater can be thought you
know or conceived or however you want to
translate it
and then from there we get you know god
existing but also god is everything it's
better to be than not to be
um which is sort of echoing the
monologian and then by by the time we
get to chapter 15
god is greater than that which we can
conceive and
you know anselm has to
figure out how it is we can know
anything about god right so
the people who deal with this the most
anselm would be one of them i mean he's
a benedictine monk
uh devoting his life to this sort of
thing um
they think that we can't know that that
much right so
all right uh
make angel would you do a series related
to psychoanalysis i already have i did a
series on freud of core concept videos
on freud's introductory lecture 31 so
you know i'll probably do more in the
future but you know i've already done it
uh reverb do you think it's worth
watching any of peterson's lectures or
it's something to be avoided i mean why
would you watch somebody who's at best
third rate when you could be spending
your time
reading seneca right or
reading something that's worthwhile i
mean peterson there's nothing you're
going to get out of peterson that's
valuable that you can't find in somebody
else
and
a lot with spending the time with
peterson you're wasting your time on
some guy who's like off base on so many
other things and is a terrible example
of of you know what a
intellectual would you know look like so
why bother you know i mean and you can
say that about so many other people
when you're when you're watching them or
reading them you have to ask is this
really
a valuable use of my time you know what
else should i be doing instead
all right i'm not going to take
everybody's stuff obviously because we
have more questions that are going to be
answered we're in the last 10 minutes
um
so let's see what we got that's that's
really interesting
okay so
chris when self studying through the
works of western philosophy do you
recommend keeping one's readings to just
the philosophical books or taking breaks
with other authors or genres what's a
good balance it's up to you i mean
you're your project
it's your brain if you want to just
spend time for a year just reading
philosophy
that's your choice you know if you want
to read other stuff that's perfectly
legitimate too there's nobody looking
over your shoulder
saying oh you have to read this and
write an essay on it or anything like
that you know you read what you want to
read
you'll find that a lot of good
literary stuff often has references to
philosophy i mean why do we teach
dostoyevsky in philosophy classes like
my existentialism class when he's not a
philosopher because there's so much
philosophy in in his uh novels and and
short stories right um philip k dick
ursula kayla green these are people who
you know bring up a lot of interesting
philosophical things either explicitly
like dick does or implicitly like ursula
k le guin does so you can you know you
can find stuff that's well worth
reading
um
all right
jacob stanley says do you ever think
about the possibility you may end up an
incredibly
influential philosopher considering the
reach of your channel it's used by a lot
of younger students as a study resource
no not really
and here's why there's famous and then
there's youtube famous right and even by
youtube famous uh
uh
criteria i'm not really that famous
um you know i've got at this point about
110 000 subscribers and
i think i've got like 10 million views
um and that's that's very cool and i'm
really happy to find out that people use
the videos
not just as a substitute but to help
them
read texts and understand thinkers
that's all really awesome
but that's that's a drop in the bucket
compared to some of the other bigger
more glitzy
high production channels that you can
find out there i think
um
and
you know
philosophy youtube is a tiny little
sliver of youtube more generally i mean
you know you bring up peterson right
peterson is not going to be remembered
as anything important 20 years from now
um
and look at how many views he has right
compared to to me so i don't know i i
mean
it i'll put it to you this way
if i do how did you put it uh becoming
an incredibly influential philosopher
that would be very very surprising to me
all i want to do is like i'm kind of
working at the lower level i want people
to understand philosophy better and
turns out that i had a skill for
explaining things
um and not turning people off that much
although i turn some people off you look
at the comments that i get sometimes um
the other thing to keep in mind too is
we don't know what's going to happen
with youtube right
we're right now we're on it we're
communicating we're i'm creating a video
with this and there'll be kind of a
lasting trace but
i mean youtube could disappear tomorrow
right that's part of why i keep my my
videos on an external hard drive as well
so i could re-upload them to some other
platform but maybe we won't have this
kind of platform 20 years from now 50
years from now
i don't know you know
so yeah
all right um
let's see here
curtis ring of fire says seneca or
cicero brian johnson or bonn scott
i mean frankly when it comes to the ac
dc thing i like bon scott better than
brian johnson um
seneca or cicero i mean if i had to
choose between the two i'd probably
choose cicero
but i don't know why we always have to
have these these this or that i mean uh
uh
why not why not both end
all right
oh here's a good one from max mackin
what would you say would be the main
thing you've learned from hegel's
phenomenology of spirit
i mean i brought it up earlier
i think hegel is right ideas we learn
what they really are when they get
brought into the realm of the actual and
they almost always turn out to be very
different than what we have in mind when
we're when we're talking about them when
we implement ideas that is the test of
what the idea really is for hegel you
know again i mentioned
hegel is an idealist but he's a
pragmatic or practical
idealist rather than like an you know
airy high in the clouds everything is a
formula kind of idealist
so yeah
um
christopher eggett do you have any
favorite literature
in the sci-fi fantasy side of things um
i have a lot of
authors and series that i really really
like i mean i think everybody knows i'm
a huge fan of ursula k le guin and
philip k dick who by the way went to
high school together but didn't know
each other
i have really enjoyed uh the r scott
backer stuff that i have uh read but
it's all been
um
you know in his second apocalypse series
i haven't read like uh
oh no i'm blanking on the names of the
others um and then who else do i i
really really enjoy
um
taneth lee i really like um carl edward
wagner
i really enjoy his stuff i wish he
hadn't died so so young
kind of a tragic life that that poor
poor bastard had
um
you know there's all sorts of others i
mean i've enjoyed going back to roger
zelazny and somebody else who i
i'd heard about and then when i read i
was like holy crap this is good cj chera
i really like her stuff as well so yeah
that's probably enough right there
um
let's see
book recognizes from boomer anderson
book recommendations on post-modernism
there is a book called the post-modern
condition by jean-francois leotard
that would be the one
and then friedrich jameson has
post-modernism the cultural logic of
late capitalism i mean if somebody is
going to complain about post-modernism
but they haven't actually read those
works i just dismiss them they don't
know what the hell they're talking about
because those are like
really uh
key works in the literature i would say
um
let's see
who else we have um
oop just skipped again
dan says how important is it to know a
language other than english when
studying philosophy
well if you're only reading english
language philosophy maybe not as much
but
man if you want to study hegel and you
don't read german you're kind of at a
disadvantage right or nietzsche or if
you want to read
the stoics and you don't actually read
latin for seneca and also cicero or
greek for
marcus aurelius who wrote in greek by
the way or epictetus
and you know
other people who write on stoicism
um heracles writes in greek you're kind
of at a disadvantage right you never
know if a translation is particularly
good or not
um so it it depends it
what what are you what's the point of
the reading you know are you trying to
um
you know work at things in a scholarly
way well there's a reason why we have
research language requirements at
masters and phd levels in philosophy in
good programs
[Music]
but you know if you're just going to
read it to try to improve your mind you
don't have to like i mean so here's a
good example right seneca's on benefits
do you have to learn latin before you
can read this very nice translation by
um
miriam griffin and brad inward bran and
brad inward i know his work he's a great
scholar on stoicism and hellenistic
philosophy in general
put out by university of chicago
um
no i mean
they did the work for you right so
actually here's another example my own
book right
it's translations that that i did from
french um you know there there's people
who do the work for you right so
it really depends um
[Music]
all right uh
mike when reading plato
is there a way to find references to
what aristotle wrote about those issues
you could read aristotle that would be
one way to do it that would be awfully
time consuming
you could also look in the scholarly
literature you know
there are and here i'd use google
scholar right and just do a couple good
search terms
you can find
articles that are going to be discussing
what aristotle had to say about about
plato sometimes aristotle tells us stuff
and we're like where the hell is this
coming from in plato you know i don't i
don't recall plato saying anything like
that
and then we're like well i don't know he
was his student you know not everything
gets written down maybe maybe the
platonus or plato did think this sort of
thing so
um
kirkland has a good thing to go out on
what do you think about marx's quote the
philosophers of the world have merely
interpreted it the point however is to
change it profound at all or just a
simple statement of intent neither i i
actually think it's a it's a silly
throwaway line that i've seen so many
people use i mean if you think that
plato didn't change the world or
aristotle didn't change the world or the
stoics didn't change the world you're
high you know and
you're not you're not a student of of
history and ideas i mean when mark said
that marx marx is a great person for
saying crap that like
sideline somebody else so that he can
like bring his project forward i mean
think about the communist manifesto a
good you know portion of it is devoted
to why everybody else gets socialism
wrong
so
um
you know
you know would be a really great
response to people when they bring up
that line it would be to say great so
what have you done to change the world
with philosophy because otherwise sit up
you know
shut up and sit down right
um there's there's so many philosophers
who have changed the world and you don't
have to change like the whole world to
have changed the world if you're um you
know
um
[Music]
if you're lev chester who only had one
really
good student who died then in the
concentration camps
you've still made an impact on people by
what you've done and you don't know what
that impact is
until much later on so that's a good one
to go out at
all right um
we'll do more of these throughout the
year thanks for everybody for your
questions i know i didn't get to
everybody but we never do
and we've got other events coming up
this this month as well that you might
want to get in on classic metal class
coming up this next saturday me and
scott truly are going to be on again
we've got the worlds of speculative
fiction the saturday after that a
political theory and practice discussion
where we're going to talk about foucault
power
and
a bunch of other stuff as well
all right hope everybody has had a great
new year and i'll see you somewhere in
the ether